quello che c'è qui sotto È qualcosa di
impressionante
ma facciamo un passo indietro
[Musica]
siamo a fine 2021 Dario mi chiama e mi
chiede se voglio partecipare al moccetti
podcast l'episodio 0 di un podcast
condotto da Dario Moccia e Simonetti che
cosa potrebbe andare storto ti è mai
capitato di fare un saluto romano Quali
sono i lati che non mostri mai di te un
cazzotto video One bimbetto a un raduno
e io vi assicuro che queste domande non
erano niente in confronto ad altre che
mi hanno fatto però vorrei non
demonetizzare questo video quindi
andiamo avanti così ed è da qui che ho
iniziato a covare la mia vendetta inizia
la nostra storia
E vabbè magari
società che gestisce il gioco di carte
più rate al mondo Magic The Gathering
annuncia una collaborazione con il
Signore degli Anelli quest'estate anche
chi non ha sfilato mai con un dito una
singola carta di Magic potrebbe
Avvicinarsi a questo meraviglioso mondo
e questa scelta di marketing avrà mai
funzionato sulle debolimenti di chi è
fan spassionato della Saga del Signore
degli Anelli
Sì ma non è finita qui la sorpresa
arriva adesso Esiste una carta che
raffigura l'unico anello avete capito
bene una sola carta in tutto il mondo ed
il suo valore stimato all'incirca sui 2
milioni di dollari ed è qui che le mie
papille gustative hanno iniziato a
riprendere a funzionare da dopo il video
Io e altri due miei amici appassionati
di carte Fedeli che Simon Abbiamo
acquistato una boxe a testa della
Booster collector del Signore degli
Anelli che potrebbero contenere la carta
dell'unico anello ovviamente è
impossibile cioè la probabilità non
esiste ma nonostante questo ci possiamo
divertire ed è qui che ho avuto
l'illuminazione
Fede senti la roba Quanto ti ci vuole a
creare una carta fake dell'unico anello
ci penso io non ti preoccupare Però
passato qualche giorno mi reco da
Federic per controllare verificare il
lavoro svolto
capito
Mamma mia l'abbiamo trovato ragazzi è
nostro sono cazzate proprio lui e
ovviamente non sarà mai come quella
originale però Potrebbe bastare per far
abboccare all'amo il Darione Nazionale
non rimane che imbustarla in uno dei
pacchetti contenuti nei box che abbiamo
preso Quindi adesso noi apriremo una
busta per infilarci Quello finto se
troviamo quello vero questo video non
finisce lo vedrete a metà e noi saremo
ai Caraibi la bustina fatta bene Quindi
Io procedo non molto più difficile
quelle Pokémon Porca miseria perfetto
mettiamo qua non dovrebbe stare alla
fine eh però ci mettiamo dentro così
Eccoci qua
serve un Attack quindi
guardavi un sacco di Art Attack da
piccolo sei bravissimo abbiamo il nostro
pacchetto esca
mi deve far fare Federico dopodiché
siamo tornati a casa e di lì a poco
saremo andati a trovare Dario Purtroppo
succede l'impensabile c'è una notizia di
merda hanno trovato l'anello che noi
abbiamo imbustato la carta siamo usciti
sono tornato a casa nel tragitto per
tornare a casa Il mio amico mi ha detto
che hanno trovato la carta
effettivamente questa è la carta quindi
ragazzi ci troviamo in mano alla sorte
perché Dario potrebbe ovviamente saprà
che l'anello è uscito Potrebbe
tranquillamente dire ma va' è una cacata
e finirla lì oppure potrebbe indagare ed
adesso parti ufficialmente lo scherzo a
Dario Moccia L'unica cosa che Dario sa è
che noi siamo lì con lui a sbustare
delle carte di Magic fine non sa
nient'altro E quindi godetevi lo scherzo
arrivati finalmente qua al bondare
quindi è Dario Moccia sono io
fa delle cose
divertenti e gli piacciono di aver mai
ricevuto una introduzione così bella e
anche sul pezzo cioè Favij appunto fosse
essere il cane
Diamond non c'è la descrizione
e poi abbiamo l'uscita Che significa a
caso
ci siamo dimenticati del cameraman di
oggi ovvero Luca mancata Eccolo
bene Dario se vuoi guardare
anche tu qualcosa
io mi posso dare un consiglio da sotto
si aprono meglio di più ce l'hai meglio
di più di più pensare No ragazzi
legalord Eccolo oh oh oh
questo è veramente una signora
alternativa ogni volta è un'ora No non
ci posso credere giufredo è una pizzica
perché è bella se fossi stata male Va
bene Ragazzi vi risparmio le 250
ore disgustate e andiamo finalmente alla
parte che ci interessa io non trovo
niente ragazzi eh raga ora voi ci ridete
ma quello che c'è qui sotto È qualcosa
di impressionante perché boh
e questa roba
[Applauso]
ragazzi
calmi che cazzo sta succedendo scusa
sta toccandola Stai toccando Che cazzo è
con la scritta in rilievo Che cazzo è
questa ragazzi Fammi chiamare Masia
ragazzi
faccio tutto Ma cos'è questa roba di che
cazzo ne so dai che è Ragazzi chi è che
ha imbustato sto pacchiano
certo certo
Ma ti rendi conto ma questa era nel tuo
box
ci occuperemo dopo non è un problema
questo però voglio capire cos'è perché
quella originale c'ha il linguaggio
elfico e rilievo Se il linguaggio
risponde allora aspetta Aspetta fammi
fare delle capiamo un attimo mi sento
male
più che altro siamo tutti diventati
ricchi cioè oggettivamente
come nella vera compagnia
è già stato trovato l'anello Comunque
magari si sono sbagliati e hanno
stampati due che andavo via eh
Ma com'è possibile allora sta tenendo
l'anello Chi ha l'anello Io non sto
salendo magari un placeholder capito Era
l'ultima carta e che ci dovrebbe essere
così questo cielo
quindi non lo so Questo è un nuovo
oggettivamente non lo so
Sì ma non la maneggiamo così Raga basta
male Eh già smintata Cioè praticamente è
uscita cioè il filmato si può rivedere
di quando l'ho aperto possiamo rivedere
il filmato dai Son contentissimo per voi
però cioè io ho avuto l'onore di fare
questa cosa Quindi Ok però voglio capire
che cos'è
Ciao Senti ci è successo una cosa strana
Non è Premetto che non è uno scherzo
Sono serissimo Ok
allora abbiamo anche il video Sono qui
con mangaka Favij Federic sono venuti a
trovarmi e c'ho altri box di del Signore
degli Anelli e abbiamo sgustato l'unico
anello quello si è realizzato uno a uno
Sì sì certo certo certo premetto non è
uno scherzo e tra l'altro spacchettato
io il pacchetto capito non è nemmeno da
di' che m'hanno fatto uno scherzo cioè
lo spacchettato Io tutto il video c'è
tutto il video Sì sì è arrivato Sile del
box questo è uscito un collector Booster
Sì sigillati l'ho aperto io il pacchetto
c'è tutto il video e un piano sequenza
dai Ciao ciao ciao raga Qualsiasi cosa
succeda non esca da qui eh no cioè cosa
dobbiamo fare niente per ora mi ha detto
metti in standby era si informa un
attimo e poi la rilevata la Sì perché
c'è la ci sono due rari in fondo Eh ora
ci si informerà raga cosa come persone
normali Sì ma se si sono sbagliati
magari immagini
preoccupava
l'abbiamo preso noi Cioè mi sembra
veramente assurdo però Infatti Oh Ma se
scusa se ti rompo il cazzo so' io allora
senti non è uno scherzo quindi Premetto
questo ok È tutto serio perché sennò
magari non mi prendi sul serio Allora i
ragazzi ha visto che avevamo portato tre
collector's box da sbustati di Signore
degli Anelli ci è successo una cosa
strana è un pacchetto che tra l'altro ho
aperto io quindi non è che m'hanno fatto
uno scherzo eccetera abbiamo trovato eh
l'anello 1 a 1 e c'abbiamo il video
tutto il video quindi questo
incontrovertibile però non so che cos'è
questa roba dai Ciao Sta arrivando il
video mi sa che c'è contenuto
il naso mi sa che c'è fuori magari
scopriamolo che non è cioè io non ho mai
fatto un video fake in vita mia
quindi
io non lo so se state facendo uno
scherzo ditemelo perché sennò maledico
sei sicuro sicuro
16 03 04 marzo sì eccolo facciamo uno
stop ora
[Musica]
Questa è la versione proxy di quello che
dell'Unione anello però l'ho trovata io
in un pacchetto base
alle scritte in rilievo la versione
originale no brillanti anche il bordo ti
tendenzialmente extra
io ho detto Magari hanno inserito lo
sapevo
pure io anche un po' paura
però non l'hanno annunciata questa roba
potrebbe anche darsi che hanno messo
dentro
mi dici il pacchetto era sigillato
Io sono ancora sì perché non sto capendo
il video scopriamo facciamo noi stiamo
facendo proprio dei notai stiamo
stoppando il video martedì 4 luglio
Questo è il video di lui che lo sbusta
poi dico delle ossa che non dico la
gente non ci crederà mai che poi è
figure di merda se si mette sto video
faccio vedere il culo ma se c'è delle
robe in questo video
chiaramente
io gioco
Sì c'è anche la stampa magari
stop stop da qui eh eh eh
sì sì sì
di stronzate ora Non voglio ricchello
originale però di stronzate quindi ha
fatto così è tutto in rilievo qua quindi
non è possibile
o robe strane Cioè a nessuno
è un problema però non è il caso di
smanacciarci
lasciamola stare un attimo Vabbè vabbè
pazienza perché se hai trovato cioè ho
trovato Vabbè comunque se avete Abbiamo
trovato una proxy ufficiale
E insomma è importante come cosa
ufficiale questa MTV Aspetta aspetta
Vabbè voi Comunque non siete normale
ragazzi sulle carte già hai toccato
un'ora Faglielo vedere prima ma non è
non ci sta dentro cioè non ci stai
dentro ci stai
tremandosi
in quanto ci avete messo a organizzarlo
Complimenti Complimenti
dopo è uscita la notizia
volevamo morire miglior attore Non
protagonista eh
Guardalo Zitto lì che sistemo le cartine
per non ridere devo dire l'ora in questo
piano a posto
16 cm 16:28 possiamo stoppare grazie
è venuto veramente un bel lampadario di
Conclusione è venuto veramente un bel
video perché ci sono a parte che siamo
pronti è difficilissimo perché siamo io
e te già che è difficilissimo poi
Lorenzo che non vedeva la vita Fede e
Simon così col denaro uscito in fase
scherzo Hahaha
Voi siete venuti a farmi lo scherzo
Ma questo erano in vacanza
Oh io ho pagato anche il pranzo
fate cagare e la mia vendetta sarà
atroce è tipo che con i miei scherzi la
gente va in ospedale Io vi mando
all'ospedale non me ne frega nulla
quindi ragazzi anche questa s'è fatta e
comunque di Karma un po' ci ha punito
perché cioè mi ha punito io c'è una
multa una multa per di parcheggio vicino
a casa di Dario dopo il mocetti podcast
non mi sento per niente in colpa bene Si
va a fare il bagno